you do ride motorbikes don't you yes
yeah but like a lot he's not your main
way of getting around yeah pretty much
yeah
little Norton commando yeah English twin
I'm sorry did you just say a Norton
commando between your legs at least one
person sitting very close to you is
imagining exactly about right
[Music]
I I saw that picture of you stabbing her
so bad but the jokes write themselves
they're not going there but if you do
fall off motorbikes a lot yeah I've had
some you know what it's a weird thing
I've had some good luck and some bad
luck you're alive that's the good luck
the bad luck is I've got a fake tooth
I've got a huge scar here I've got a I
guess a plate in my neck about this but
that's not all just the motorcycles but
yeah I've come off the bike a few times
yeah but wasn't there time you scored
your leg yeah that was the one where a
car pulled out in front of me and and I
was kind of trying to decide this was
just after I had the plate in the neck
and I was deciding if I was kind of
about to hit the car because I started
to veer but then the car saw me and
started to move and then he stopped and
then I was just like oh man what am i
good so then I was trying to decide
whether to drop the bike or to jump off
the bike and go over the car and then by
the time I kind of figured that all out
I took the bumper off of his car and I
ended up sitting on the ground and then
that bike was just lying over there and
then like toothless cut it in half and I
had blood in my mouth and then the guy
came over and he was freaking out but I
was in shock so I was like it's okay but
the thing about it is that I was getting
as I was sitting a long moment
my skin was open on my shin oh and own
white is very white
it's like so I cut tossing it in my
friend without like look how white that
is and so then this woman who came up
said it said everything okay and then
she kind of was there and the paramedics
and she was like it's a Keanu Reeves and
he's like what can I have your autograph
[Applause]
[Music]